Keith this is an incredibly scary
thought explain sort of what's involved
how do scientists even think that they
can teach a robot how to make an ethical
decision to tell my car that it should
swerve off the side of the road down a
cliff instead of colliding with a school
bus full of children yeah this is an
issue Olivia that's really be deviling
the auto industry in Google who's also
developing their own driverless car
they've figured out the technology they
know how to allow cars to drive for us
but they can't really figure out these
philosophical questions like the one you
just described and that's something
they're now working literally with
philosophers and ethicists on to try and
determine what do you do when you know a
crash is unavoidable and your car has to
decide between the lesser of two evils
hitting a school bus full of children
are going up on a sidewalk and hitting
an individual they don't have all the
answers yet well neither do individuals
Keith's right I mean it's not as if
there is a law that set in stone that
tells you how to drive but I'm wondering
what other industries or what other
historical precedent are they using to
deal with this issue well Believe It or
Not Pym I mean science fiction does play
a role here this all sounds like science
fiction doesn't it but it's you know
Asimov's laws which comes from you know
the author of irobot in the 1950s say
that you know a robot should do no harm
to a human human that's that's the first
rule there are other things like they
call it morality Matthew you try and
determine how many lives will be saved
or how few will be harmed but then
you're putting no value on those lives
so so each of these rules that they
might come up with have downsides in it
and they're still very much working
through them Keith some people say that
there has to be a principle that only
humans should be able to make a decision
between life and death and that there
needs to be some kind of hybrid
functionality going on whereby you
combine decision making of humans and
robots and I barely know what to ask you
about this so hard to get my brain
around it but how would that work yes oh
and the automaker's say this too
probably with you know liability
concerns in mind that the human is
always ultimately responsible for the
car and in those situations where
shazahn avoid unavoidable they're going
to ask the human to step back in grab
the wheel and and you know swerve it out
of the way themselves that all sounds
good in theory but if you've been
inattentive you're reading a book doing
your email you know then how can you
come back into the situation and make a
snap decision and make a good one